you get up to here during the game and
now standing outside waiting for you is
your family but you find different
techniques which gonna be you know
alcohol pills to help you you know
manage that rollercoaster
my name is Cullen Jenkins I'm a former
Super Bowl champion for the Green Bay
Packers retired thirteen year NFL
veteran
it was a rough ride for me to get into
the NFL
I was undrafted player out of Central
Michigan Green Bay side they brought me
into camp and cut me right after and so
I set out that whole year I started to
doubt myself wonder if I'd even ever
make it an NFL Green Bay signed me back
at the end of the season they sent me
over to Europe I went over to Europe
played I gained a lot of confidence I
came back went through training camp
began for the second time I made the
team
you're not played through everything is
so many injuries that you don't even you
know really keep track of them ankle
sprains knee sprain I told my PEC off
the bone they're always so people I have
no knuckle right here
I broke the bone in the game but the one
that lingered the longest was when I did
my ankle so when I went to stand up it
just gave if I couldn't walk end up
being a bone bruise and it never healed
no I ended up having to get surgery
three years later they ended up drilling
into the bone it was so bad that you
know just walking around with my family
if we go to a fair you know carnivore
and you try to walk around half an hour
45 minutes into it I'd have to sit down
and just you know rest and take a break
and you know everybody would have to
wait for me I think it's just gonna be
part of football there's no way you can
have people as big as they are you know
as fast as they are strong as they
aren't running and colliding without
there being some concussions they do all
of the the work with helmets trying to
teach different tackle ins now and you
know things to help try to limit the
amount of concussions that you get it's
gonna be there there's no way to
completely eliminate it I wouldn't say
every game but you did see a lot you
still out of it you know nothing makes
sense you couldn't remember you know the
play calls you guys to tell your
teammates sometimes you know you see the
teammates do the same with you did be
like yo can you help me out I don't know
what's going on do you just keep
learning to fight through it
managing the pain to get a have
treatment the trainer's will work with
you and they'll do whatever they can to
help you to heal and recover but that
stuff is a process and it takes time you
don't have that time you still have to
practice you still got games so by the
time you're trying to heal then you got
to go right back your agri
again for every practice I would have
the same routine I would get out of
meetings in an hour
Oh to get ready for practice then I
would take two Tylenol and four advil in
days where it was worse if much if the
pain was bad our substitute vicodins for
the Tylenol and Advil so then when the
game's over now you revved up some of
the pain meds are starting to wear off
you know now you want to try to get your
mind and just come down and relax so you
turn the alcohol you're like oh I need
to go have me a few drinks so I can
settle down to allow relax the nature of
a football you know you have to
constantly you know go from here to here
here to here and so you you try to find
the quickest ways to get up to here you
need to be here then when you're not
don't need to be there anymore you try
to find a quickest way to get back down
if I got really beat up you know in the
game then yeah I come home and not to
appeal and they're not drink with it it
will become I wouldn't necessarily say
too heavily but too often during then
you can justify it because you say this
is why I'm doing it I'm doing it because
I'm hurting you know I'm aching you know
honey to relax try to get somewhere I
just try to get some sleep but then once
football ends you know and you're still
doing it and now you're like why am I
still doing it there's no reason that
before I had an excuse now I don't have
an excuse a lot of players smoke weed
you know smoke marijuana the testing
process is an annual test
I think it's a joke to begin with
because you know it's just all you have
to do is you know have enough
self-control to stop during that testing
window so that you're clean and you can
perceive what's doing what you want to
do I never did it that often and I
wasn't one that you know do it every day
for me personally I like to kind of be
focused more you know we're kind of like
be in whenever more the right state of
mind you know throughout the day I first
got into CBD oil through family members
they talked about a lot of other
problems and pains that I was going
through and they brought me a sample of
it I didn't know anything about CBD I
heard cannabis and I thought it was just
something to get you high and so I
didn't even touch it you know I was like
whatever finally after two weeks you
know they kept asking me about it know
how does it make you feel and I'm like
alright you know it I'll finally try it
I started with the drops you know and
you take the drops and you just you know
put it under your tongue just oral oil
when I first started taking it it helped
me sleep and I was surprised because it
doesn't get too high at all and so then
I started asking questions I'm like you
know what what exactly is this and then
that's when I started learning more you
know they started explaining it to me
you know I saw that you know this stuff
can benefit you a lot it slowly started
helping me with not just a sleeping but
with pains my energy level will be
higher during the day because I'm
sleeping better at night inflammation
that I would have will start being
better and going down and it was
something that was very surprising to me
whatever reasons I got involved in it is
pretty simple fact that I liked it so
much when you go to something that you
tried and you say you know wow what is
this you know this really helps how come
I've never heard about this before so
then you do the research and you see
that it's not available everywhere you
know something that's up and coming and
people don't understand so we're trying
to spread the word to get people
knowledgeable and understanding about
what exactly CBD is
[Music]
from the business standpoint I think
that it's great I think that it can
eliminate a lot of dystopian crisis and
help with a lot of different things for
people in dealing with the pharmacy you
know I got involved in we came up with
fresh farm CBD we've got the oils we've
got sports balms education was something
that was a big part for me and that's
why I really like the role that I'm
playing in this nurse because I get to
help educate other people that were just
as you know ignorant to it as I was as
you hear anything with cannabis or hemp
and all you think of is getting high and
smoking weed but once you're educated
and once you do the research you realize
that that CBD isn't even doing any of
those things
[Music]
if it is illegal why opiates are illegal
with adderall you know all the
medications like that you know they test
you for them but if you're prescribed by
a doctor and you get it you know and you
get it documented and signed then it's
okay
no telling you know what is you know
does to you internally you know from
taking all of the peels and you know the
pharmaceutical drugs that you get so I
don't understand you know why they're
lagging behind with the CBD if it's just
here for the benefit of healing you then
why won't we a lot of players to do it
especially if it can help prevent them
from being addicted to these drugs or
having these bad side effects from these
drugs being introduced to the CBD oil
has really helped me to to focus on more
healthier ways of trying to go forward
with my life and getting away from the
old bad habits now you know without
taking that stuff and just taking though
the oils you know I'm able to wake up
feeling refreshed so you have more
energy you know you go through the day
your outlook is different because now
you're not you're not looking for that
escape from things
[Music]
you
[Music]